[Music]
for the last year
guys for the last year we've been doing
this singing competition yeah and um we
got amazing submissions not only
masterpieces and uh this is us some
music from one of the winners winner
yeah we have a couple winners yeah this
is songs
and we were truly impressed and
congratulations enjoy hey kingdom i'm
jack champ and today i'm performing the
tiger belly song
uh if you feel like checking out more of
my music or anything like that
here's where you can go
and the soldiers papaya
thanks
[Music]
[Applause]
also
[Music]
is
can i just say this podcast be the best
one only five two but the attitude is
ten one used to be a wrestler so better
not offend em you might need a doctor if
you mistaken him for ken jung
[Music]
how can that be the case with the skin
routine of taking bacon burgers
[Music]
is
my name is brandon and
today i will be singing the tiger belly
theme you can find my music at grand
underscore paw underscore vern on
instagram
and we have a couple singles out on
spotify you can just look us up it's
grandpa vern
uh my band is a punk project
and yeah and today i will be doing the
tiger belly theme so i'll just get right
into it
[Music]
i'm a giant
thank you
hey guys my name is sloane i'm going to
be singing the tiger belly theme song
this week if you do want to listen to
more of my music you can head to my
youtube channel or my instagram
[Music]
what's up everybody my name is dwayne
higgins and i'm singing the tiger belly
song this week uh thank you to everybody
that watched and commented nice things
and thank you to bobby kalila and the
whole crew
uh for electing me as one of the winners
so
uh you can check out the music my music
at dwayne higgins.com follow me on
instagram and all that good stuff uh
thanks guys
i might get a little sexual with you
nick
[Music]
me
hey
[Music]
um
be
[Music]
yo what's going on everybody my name is
devin and i'm singing the tiger belly
theme song this week if you like what
you hear please add me on instagram
devindemyto and add me on spotify and
apple music as devin dean thank you so
much
[Music]
me
my
[Applause]
[Music]
so